I'm Naomi Brockwell for recent survey
I'm here at the New York City Bitcoin
Center located right in the financial
district of New York where there are all
sorts of interesting activities going on
involving this new peer-to-peer currency
let's take a look I was in college now
instead of going to college I'm doing
Bitcoin because you know there's no
college class on Bitcoin except in
Cyprus and I'm not ready to move there
this technology will change human
networking forever bitcoins role in the
future is nearly limitless right bitcoin
is a virtual currency why does it need a
physical location oh well we're here on
the Wall Street we have market makers
come in every day stockbrokers
investment banks and we teach them
Bitcoin 101 takes about four hours and
every single one of them works out
amazing
one of the main Monday night activities
that happens at the Bitcoin center is
called Satoshi Square where Bitcoin
traders can meet up face-to-face and
exchange cash of the coins we are
hosting up on the board everyone who's
buying and selling or wishing to buy and
sell bitcoins tonight commerce has been
conducted in the city centers since the
beginning of time what is the hackathon
that has been happening here at the
Bitcoin Center so the hackathon started
on Friday and basically a bunch of
people got together started making a
project anything Bitcoin related you
know you can work from home you can work
here but you have about three days to
complete a project and then it's gonna
be presented it's going to be judged by
a group of people on challengepost
gotta iron it on
and then guess what
voila we got him out to Senegal Cyprus
and Nairobi what kind of currency does
it accept all currencies I'm actually
turning electricity into cash and how
I'm doing that is I have built this
machine right here and what it does is
it helps out cryptocurrency networks
like Bitcoin and in return for the help
on the network I'm rewarded by the
network and coins
so you're basically mining bitcoins at
the moment yes this is a mining machine
and it mines bitcoins like coins any
coin what is your personal interest in
Bitcoin why did you get involved in
Bitcoin in the first place that's pretty
good question I don't really know
I feel inflation is due to over printing
of dollars maybe people just by learning
about Bitcoin would slow down the
dollars being printed as an educational
function of its existence Bitcoin is
what the world is becoming decentralized
networks is how the world is progressing
and as far as a physical place for that
the Bitcoin Center NYC is the center of
the world right now
you